a lot of films nowadays are films that
you can watch with your eyes closed
everything is being told to you rabbit
is a film that is about experience of
seeing and hearing we want it to be an
emerging experience as if you're sitting
in the theatre but you feel as if you're
floating space explore you do you copy
there's no other format is immersive
assignments
when we were designing the film we were
clear that we didn't want to do a
futuristic film we wanted to make a film
that takes place today we know the Space
Shuttle is out of circulation but we
wanted to incorporate it because to this
point of space exploration in audiences
consciousness the Space Shuttle is part
of what they know we wanted to be as
accurate as possible with those
references we needed to explore the
design of the Hubble telescope the
shuttle the ISS International Space
Station I think our biggest reference
was the Kabul documentary
that for me is my personal favorite
dynamics IMAX was our Bible resolution
in the detail was available we would
explore the way in which astronauts move
in space and the amazing craziness that
is action-reaction when you are in zero
gravity with no resistance when I was
about three months into my space station
mission my brother met Sandra Bullock's
brother-in-law and they arranged that
she and I would talk because she was
about to go to space we talked about how
there's outside wearing the 300 pound
spacesuit and always holding on to
something and then there's inside the
space station where it just takes the
touch of a finger or even I could take
one of my long hairs and push it against
us
of us and I could move myself down the
entire length of the space station
that's how little force it takes to move
up there somebody did their homework
because everything is exactly like it
was on our mission it's a very linear
very contained story is in one hand it's
very intimate but with the backdrop of
space this historical experience is as
important as the journey of the
character when you see that in a huge
screen you get to see every single
detail
terrific it's so beautiful to see them
working with the earth in the background
you can see the planet in its entirety
it's either curvature like we would see
when the action begins to happen we
start following our character in a very
close one person narrative
become addicts the approach of following
the POV of the astronaut that is just
rolling or spinning in space
together we dirty the sound mix that is
very vain now
everything is moving around that is I
see during the center of an orchestra
the IMAX format I think captured the
emotion of what it's like to be there in
the time of crisis but we had a better
day I'll go through you and they did it
crabby when you go to the movies when
you walk in that door and you sit in
that seat you were asking someone to
take you somewhere and probably
somewhere you can't go by yourself you
know the big format the beautiful used
brings back a lot of good memories
I believe in magic and a film like this
in this IMAX format you get to go